you
I don't even know how to use the menus
I'm just pretending like a what do you
think the toughest thing will be today
making a decision on which shots coolest
because they're all gonna be pretty good
these guys are really good pilots and
that's like an understatement
a system like a DJI phantom where you
can only go so this far answer stuff now
you can get you can get different angles
that you could you couldn't dream of
before cuts back to front cam we're
still like we're still down there kind
of like dodging some stuff that's
intense and then we cut out and we're
like but got it made oscillations here
really hot motors oh that's not good
I've never ever smelled my motors uh-huh
it happens a biga to hunt they melt
I would hazard a guess that because
because the GoPro is not really solidly
mounted as probably just getting some
kind of resonant frequency every
physical object has some sort of
frequency that it internally vibrates
that and if you were to put a vibration
on that object at the same frequency
they it builds to a point that it just
shakes out of control yeah it's fine
ready get out of here let's go oh we got
red yeah Touche
I like to like have a lot of little like
hobbies on the side of filmmaking one
thing I've always been interested in is
history people that came before us and
being like wow like there's so much to
discover here numismatics is the study
of coins and their history and
collecting them you can buy these
ancient Roman coins that have been dug
out of the ground they ship them to you
usually you have no idea what you have
I'm ordering these coins right here I
finally received this package yeah I
wrote my name on there and everything
they are so Wow is there huh this one
that's a big one so these are uncleaned
Roman coins from about the 2nd to 4th
century AD there's a couple that I
cleaned a while ago coin from
Constantius the second reign and then
this one has it was just beautiful
patina you can really see there's a
little face there guy has a little
headband Constanta is the second himself
so it doesn't look like much when you
get it so if you guys are interested
I'll show you guys what I find when when
they're all clean and if I can identify
them then that'll be a fun little
mystery to solve
ways let's see it we have line of sight
down there which is pretty solid
right so that wasn't combined ren with
cameras like i need attention are we not
getting enough attention Ren do we need
to put you into the vlogs more so if
these guys crash here if they smash to
the side of bridge they're drones going
into the river this is a scene where
they have to do something dangerous and
it to do it without crashing because the
drones gone if they do not even nobody
will know how to get down there yeah
that looked balls I'm gonna do that
again [ __ ]
oh god damn it
so they've crashed Joan and now they're
going to go find it hey Carmichael good
luck go explore
the Ingalls is quote we do cross here
okay it's a little bit stiffer
further down the river guys will stand a
pot will get you start the motor to see
if we can hear it here it is yes you
[ __ ] any broke broke one prop - yes
dick yeah we got the whole thing she's
still recording everything's a-okay well
you guys got you crash yeah there you go
can't steal a life from the mountain
mountain always gets even
another computer stopped working by the
way guys if you do this you're an
[ __ ]